[Music]
every esport
boasts those filthy frustrating
forces of nature known as mains
it doesn't matter if you're a league
scrub are still playing overwatch for
some reason or
can't help but subject yourself to that
sadomasochistic
nightmare that is dota you've definitely
encountered some dedicated
die-hard devotees who've literally
spammed their way
to success he puts themselves up that's
it
and it's looking like he looks so
focused on the wobble right now
singularly minded masters who at the
risk of being hamstrung
say counters be damned set out to learn
everything there is to know about the
character they're so hell-bent on
hardlining
and make it their sole purpose to clap
any one
and anything that stands in their way
winning games with
nature profit is probably the most
enjoyable thing i mean it's become kind
of a meme people spam the twitch chat
about it and
slowly getting split pushed and you
can't do anything about it you're just
pushing out waves
and waiting for your doom so i don't
think my enemies like me so much for it
but
you know who cares oh both seven he was
farming up the ancients and now admiral
bulldog has found him
backtracks galore but it's still bone
seven gonna fall inside that side the
fight
because at the end of the day that's
what makes for a true
mane someone who can use one set of
skills to overcome
every obstacle that's shoved in their
path
someone whose conversance with a certain
character is
so opie that they can find a solution
to any problem firing the second take
nearly gonna be there jonah oh man
this takes them down right up in the
face of a bastion fights a triple kill
as kino and arc
also fall let's go ahead and make it
four you got more for me
let's go ahead and say it samsung's
gonna be dumping the bomb trying to make
it back in but there it is
gets them in the face and then why excel
just take the point on the back of jonah
but what if i told you that in the
ever-growing esport that is valerant
the most shining example of that wasn't
a seasoned
professional or some certifiably cracked
up-and-comer
what if i told you that the game's most
sought-after
savants was actually an opera singer
meet jonas average jonas navarsite
the norwegian songbird who after years
of authoring musical parodies around his
favorite esports
finally got his big break not as a
musician
mind you but as a theory crafter who's
quickly solidifying himself
as his game's nuttiest sova specialist
all right they're still in there wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i have a lineup for it
do it do it it's coming it's coming oh
is it a thing
please
dude jonas
so how did jonas go from belting out
arya's to slinging sonar arrows
what inspired him to start hunting down
such insane lineups to begin with
and in what sense is he becoming a sort
of celebrity in the valorant community
at large amazing
darts how sweet they
sound
okay so as with a lot of valorance early
adopters
jonas hails from a background of
surprise surprise
counter-strike but that's not all he
hails from and it isn't at
all how his youtube channel got its
start a vocalist by trade
jonas started uploading creative
acapella renditions of mainstream pop
music
way back in 2013. from there he began
delving into movie soundtracks
musicals christmas carols video game
themes
and of course his specialty operator
i started singing a choir and uh
when i was singing in a choir i was
always i always had a lot of fun
doing all the other voices too so like
when i heard the sopranos sing i was
like wait maybe i should try this
soprano too
and then i tried the tenor and then i
you know and then i was like and
when i was like walking home from choir
practice i would like
have all the different voices basically
i had voices in my head i don't know if
that's a good thing but
so so then i i was like what if i just
record
all of this how how will that sound the
thing is
jonas was also something of an e-gamer a
lifelong
lover of shooters jonas began authoring
and uploading musical parodies
centered around titles such as gta 5
overwatch
and like any self-respecting
scandinavian cs go
and then of course counter-strike came
into the picture as the more like
mechanical
challenging pvp aspect which i think
more uh makes sense in terms of like the
competitive aspect
i think for most people that play world
of warcraft they don't play
to compete that much against others but
maybe
compete against yourself in the same way
like i can't actually play you any of
them because of copyright but
suffice it to say jonas's catalog boasts
such classics as
let it blow eco maybe and
hello from the trading site
unfortunately
churning out acapella content by
yourself requires a
ton of work and in the end it just
wasn't worthwhile for jonas to give his
full attention to his perotic passion
projects
now part of the reason for this was his
talent in the server
you see jonas wasn't just an appreciator
of fps but
kind of an aficionado someone who had
the makings of an
actual competitor he even spent most of
2016 trying to crack it as a
professional overwatch player
serving as the main tank for a slew of
lesser-known norwegian stacks
and for epiphany bolt we have a sort of
new lineup this is not the whole team
that qualified
since they have gotten some roster
changes but we will see
globe tricky average jonas as their team
leader riku
lee sin lysine and dave playing now a
little bit back and forth misfits
playing very aggressively now as he don
falls and newbig and oh a huge earth
shatter
is gonna stop the team and their tracks
and misfits are now being
forced back five members going down an
epiphany vault looking very strong
alas jonas's dream of becoming a
full-time
reinhardt spammer simply wasn't meant to
be
i also quickly realized that
mechanically i would not be able to keep
up with the best in the world
and i also think it was due to like a
conflict of interest with what
because i was also doing music at the
time and studies
so there was like a lot of things to
balance out and not a lot of spare time
despite taking his competitive career
out to pasture after
only three months he stuck around the
scene for years to come
doing everything he could to support
norwegian overwatch
hey guys my name is jonas and i'm the
community manager of team norway
overwatch
we're going to los angeles to play in
the world cup
needless to say said involvement
wouldn't last see this was back when
franchising was being hailed as the
future of esports and
overwatch the savior of competitive
gaming unfortunately blizzard did what
they always do
get too involved ruin everything and
watch as their esport collapses in on
itself like a dying star
for nearly two years jonas was pretty
much off the radar
he all but gave up on youtube and
shifted his attention back onto music
which landed him a job singing on a
cruise ship
so i i basically sent my resume uh to
silversea cruise lines so that's where i
ended up
somehow a little mountain boy from
norway and uh
so there was quite a lot of uh yeah
quite a lot of things i needed to change
up in my head it was a big challenge but
i don't think i've learned
more from anything else in a span of 10
months
like you change so much as a performer
and a person
not just from the actual shows but from
traveling the world meeting new cultures
and to live in a 12 square meter
little bedroom together with another
person with no window
because regardless of how luxurious the
cruise ship is and the switch for the
guests are
believe you me the crew do not have the
same benefits
and then in the spring of 2020 right as
everything seemed to be going on track
for jonas
covet happened jonas lost his job in the
craziest way imaginable was left
temporarily stranded in brazil
thousands of miles away from home but
after making it back to norway
jonas found himself jobless and without
so much as a prospect in either esports
or music
he was lost and then out of nowhere
jonas caught a break riot games released
their long-awaited hero shooter one that
sought to fuse the shooting mechanics of
counter-strike with the ability mayhem
of overwatch and for jonas valerant
wasn't just an opportunity to create new
content
it was a dream come true
[Music]
sure valorant offered jonas a new stage
to pursue his penchant for parody
but on top of that it allowed him to
pursue a
new kind of content creation see having
really gone the distance with overwatch
jonas was of a different breed than most
of the purebred counter-strike converts
who'd flooded valoran's
servers early on he was a sucker for
spells
especially those that rewarded
resourcefulness and creativity which
invalorant honestly isn't
actually that many okay now already i
know what you're gonna say
valerian's hero abilities make it ten
times more varied and sophisticated than
cs go
and in a sense you'd be correct but that
doesn't mean that it isn't a
shitload more accessible now to be clear
this
isn't a bad thing at all one of the
truly great things about riot's brand
spanking new shooter is that it found a
way to
streamline the often incredibly obtuse
utility requirements of counter strike
like if we're playing valorent and i
tell you
smoke off spawn there's nothing to it
you either whip out your
circular mass of inter-dimensional mist
or you simply pull out your ipad
click it on the minimap and whoop brims
your uncle but if we're playing cs go
that's a whole other story let's say
you've looked up
where to throw the smoke grenade from
have you lined it up using your
crosshair in particular
is it a standing throw a slow walk a
crouch walk a running toss
does it require a jump bind and if so
will it work on 64 tick servers
or 128 tick and that's just smokes
in valorent for instance my boy phoenix
can execute an altogether
perfect pop flash just by pressing a
button to pull off something like that
in cs you'd need to spend
countless hours learning how to conduct
a symphony orchestra with the damn thing
content creation landscape pretty much
being a blank canvas
and with most people still just learning
the ropes
jonas saw an opportunity to put his
creative talents to work
and he saw it with one agent in
particular
wherever they run i will find them
now for those who are unaware sova's kit
revolves around a set of sonar and shock
arrows that can be bounced around the
game world with near
infinite possibilities and because of
that he boasts
a skill floor that's basically higher
than most other agents
ceilings and being the jonas was a true
strategist
the kind who lived not only to compete
but to theorycraft
his interest in sova's kit became a
calling of sorts
an obsession that could never be quelled
and i
saw silva and i was like okay there's a
lot of potential
in this agent like there's a lot of cool
stuff you can do
and i also could see that there's so
much stuff that no one's done yet with
sova
but at the same time it kind of
frightened me because i know how i work
as like approaching any sort of
knowledge
that if i choose soba i have to choose
him
like i can't just like casually play
silver now and then and that's gonna be
fine
within no time he was releasing his very
own lineup videos
assembling a modest but fast-growing
twitch community
and cementing himself as the sort of mad
scientist who was gleefully ripping
servers apart with his 2 billion iq
arrows
[Laughter]
what's more jonas was this joyful
jubilant
sweetheart who was banging out while he
was fragging out
because i'm a sober mane check the curvy
then you know my name
i upload all my clips to gain ready
chip i think one of the reasons why
people enjoy my content is that i never
rage
and i'm never toxic so that like i'm
trying to just be as relaxed as possible
i'm getting off now i'm quitting
one of the big advantages of being a
quote-unquote boomer like you have
traveled a lot seen a lot met a lot of
people learned a lot of different social
interactions and you can kind of
use all this knowledge when you're
when you're teaching other people how to
do a certain things
whether he was executing one of his
signature double shock lineups
it's going to look like this
this one is super deadly because it's
really hard to see it coming
and it lands really tight right there in
the space where he peaks
or competing in actual tournaments the
better
of the omens thus far here comes jonas
in with two kills and mitt's going to
shut him down sure enough but myth
l needs much more and instead he hits
the floor
it's the nordics on the board jonas's
sova centric
slap fests were quite literally taking
valorant
by storm and it wasn't long before tens
of thousands of like-minded followers
joined him on his lineup discord even
pro
players started taking note of his nutty
ass arrows i think
the thing that the reason why a lot of
people
ended up using my guides and my lineups
even in pro play now i see
like a lot of my lineups being used in
pro tournaments which i think is super
cool because that shows that regardless
of the skill level this is still very
relevant because no matter how
good or bad you are at aiming there is
always a higher skilled ceiling
that's in ability usage and as jonas's
strategy
skyrocketed in popularity so too
did his streaming ahead
he was even selected to be a color
caster for valerian's first
major tournament first strike where he
was invited to inject a little bit of
energy
into more than just the play-by-play
[Music]
the sky
you planted staring
at the ground
and for that you
to die and as if 2020 hadn't been
life-changing enough for jonas in 2021
he was brought in as a full-time content
creator for team liquid
a side stacked rush
this feels like a a home where i can now
do all these things because
there's a production team here there's a
manager here so now we're looking at all
these kind of music producers around
europe where we can do
projects together and the irony is that
by
not choosing to go full-time musician
like i used to
i'll now probably get more exciting
music gigs that i would ever get
from focusing on music in the first
place which is super ironic
from choir boy to opera singer to
youtuber to professional overwatch
player
to valorance resident sova specialist
jonas boasts one of the craziest stories
of
any content creator in the whole of
esports
and it's not lost on you know now i'm
basically
what can i i'm living the dream like
there's not much else to say like
of course people constantly ask me would
you go back to your old job if you could
i'm like no absolutely not
it's just that this is something that
it's impossible to imagine yourself
doing unless you're
suddenly there as you can see jonas's
story is
anything but run-of-the-mill he had to
become brilliant at a bunch of things
and overcome a ton of adversity before
he
finally found his true calling the
perfect
gig that somehow combined all of the
absurdly
disparate things he'd ever been good at
so i think first of all i think that uh
what i'm doing now is like a full circle
of everything i've been doing for like
the past 10
15 years because it's been gaming it's
been competing
it's been singing if there's one thing
to be learned from our boys
astronomical rise to the top it's this
life like valorant isn't entirely
susceptible to lineups
try as you might to plan things out to a
t something crazy
chaotic and altogether unpredictable can
and will happen that's what makes
tactical shooters so
interesting it's also what makes life so
interesting
but it's jonas's ability to be both a
meticulous
painstakingly precise planner and
someone who's proven that he can roll
with the punches
that's made him so damn successful which
is guys
[Laughter]
that match on saturday or on sunday
between vitality and
uh navi hits 660
000 concurrent viewers the most of any
online match for cs in history
like but it's a dead game that's a dead
game you're just pissed because cs go is
a dead game bro
you just spit like all right fam like
sure